[Music]
J
to
some
what
l
should
ch
e
e for
hello everyone ooh that's a fun
sound thank you for coming today thank
you so much just happy to see
everybody's wonderful faces even on this
rainy day um couple of announcements as
we get started uh tonight is hat Creek
night so uh first Sunday of the month
after service we meet at hat Creek um
and we do just kind of fellowship and
food um hat Creek is right off of 78 um
if you need help finding it uh you can
find me after the service and or one of
many other people will be able to help
you as well um but everyone is welcome
to join so please feel free to join us I
will be there so you can probably find
me in my incredibly loud shirt with ease
um second announcement uh this is the
table's fifth year so in honor of that
we're doing a 5year anniversary uh
celebration which will be a chili
cookoff um I did win last year the chili
cookoff just a note um but we will be
doing that immediately after service on
the 17th so um that will be here so make
sure you sign up get your recipes ready
there is a uh QR code when you look at
the QR code whenever that pops up after
the service probably um or right there
you can click that in it we will'll have
a link to sign up for the chili cook off
as well on the 17th so I'm excited about
that I hope yall are
too um and then now for the more uh
reverent
stuff um so we've lit these candles
tonight um they are sign of presence of
Christ Among Us his fully Divine fully
human form um so as we exit the kingdom
of
noise hurry and
productivity we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a place for prayer for
worship and adoration a place to behold
Christ the revelation of God the
heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart and
may we all come home
today thank you Jared this was his
person that night doing announcements
can you guys give him a
hand well done man
all right would you guys like to stand
with us we're going to get started um
with good God tonight and uh a few of
you I don't recognize your faces so let
me just be the first to say that this
space this worship time together is for
each one of us to enter in um we really
want you guys to be just as much a part
of the music as we are up here so if we
can kind of imagine that there is no
division between this stage and those
seats but that we are all invited in to
this creative experience where God wants
to meet us in these words he wants to be
here with us he wants us to feel his
presence and his nearness um As we sing
words that we believe and we pray will
be true in our own lives so please sing
along as you're comfortable if you would
rather sit and soak and um meditate
during this you're also welcome to do it
this space is for each one of us so
let's worship together tonight all right
[Music]
let's s be
still be still my
soul Be Still My
Soul be still know that my God is
here he still my soul
Be Still My
Soul be still and know that my God is
here all that I need to know is this you
are a good God the maker of heaven calls
me his you are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest you are a good God all
that I have to do is rest you are we
[Music]
good sing I won't be
afraid I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is here
he'll make a way he will make a way
he will make
way he will make a way my God is here
all that I need to know is this you are
a good God the maker of heaven calls me
is you are a good God and your heart
beats in my chest you are with good God
all that I have to do is rest you you
are with
[Music]
good me your me your
heart I'm sorry you me your me your your
spirit flows through my let's sing that
again you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart
your spirit flows through my ve you gave
me your eyes you gave me your heart your
spirit flows through my vein and you
gave me your eyes you gave me your heart
you had a plan right from the start and
I know who I am cuz I know who you are
you
[Music]
are all that I need to know is
this the maker of heaven CL
me all that I need to know is this you
are a good God the maker of heaven calls
me head you are a good God and your
heart beats in my you are a
good all that I have to do is rest you
are a good God you are a good
God you are a
good you are a good God you
are all right kiddos y'all are dismissed
to go to your classes thanks for being
here with us tonight we hope you have
fun your teachers will meet you over by
the
doors thank you Chloe and August
Kelly we appreciate you guys so much
loving on our kids every
week we're going to move into the
prayers of the people and um this is a
tradition throughout Christian history
um that we like to participate in each
week just acknowledging that we all
carry things into this space together um
pains struggles things that are heavy on
our hearts and we want to lift those up
before our community and before God um
so so if you guys would follow along on
the screens you can repeat the parts or
um read aloud the parts in red with us
and then we'll leave some space in the
middle of the prayer for you to name out
loud a name or a situation that's on
your heart and then we'll close out the
prayer together
again Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
[Music]
amen God is so good
God is so
[Music]
good
God is so good she's so good
to
God is so
good
good is so
good she so good
tothy of every song we could ever
[Music]
sing Worthy of all the praise we could
ever
[Music]
bring worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could ever
SA
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for
you sing
Holy
Holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and tell
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love To
those
me worthy of every song we could ever
[Music]
sing worthy of all the praise we could
ever
bring you
worthy of every breath we could ever
Brea we live for
you we live for
[Music]
you Jesus the name above every other
name Jesus the only one who could ever
s worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for
you we live for
you and
H there is no one like you there is none
beside you oh open up my eyes in Wonder
and show me who you are and fill me with
your heart and Lead me any love to those
around
[Music]
me I will
build
life your
love is a firm found
I will put my trust in you
alone and I will not be Shen and I will
build my life upon your
love is a fir
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone I will not be one more time and I
will build my life upon your
love is a firm
foundation I will build my trust in you
alone and I will not be
Shen
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love to those around me and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In your
love to
those
[Music]
[Laughter]
around
God is so
[Music]
good
God is so good
heart is so
good she's so
[Music]
good
me
she cares for
me she she cares for
me she's so
[Music]
good love
her love her
love her
soul she's so
good
to God is so
God is so
good
God is so good
is so
good she is so
good
[Music]
to
God we want to believe and build our
life on that
truth that you are a good God
that you are on the side of the broken
and the weary and the
needy God that you see us at our
lowest you see us when we
struggle when we're filled with
shame when we are tired and beaten down
and you meet us there in our need
God God your word says that you give us
Wings to mount up as
Eagles God that you set your feet upon a
rock that you lift us from muck and Meer
your word said blessed are the
poor blessed are those who hunger and
thirst for
[Music]
righteousness and God in this life I
find myself very poor so
often and it is our good that we know a
god God who is with us in the
pit who meets
us when we make our bed in the
valley that you are an anchor in our
storm God would we root ourself into
those
truths would they hold us fast
would they become the common thread of
our
life in every season in every struggle
in every
Joy would you be there at the center
holding
us our source and our greatest good
thank you for who you are would we only
come to know it more and more and share
it with this broken World in Jesus name
amen thank you guys for worshiping with
us tonight would you turn to the people
around you and say hello um before we
move on
well Grace and peace it is good to be
with you all my name is Brett and uh
yeah it's a joy a joy to see your faces
and uh also want to extend a welcome to
those joining online love you all you're
not forgot
remember to get your communion stuff for
later in the service and also want to
extend a warm welcome to uh anyone who's
new whether this is your first time or
maybe first few times and it can just be
a little you know anxiety inducing just
a little difficult sometimes and uh
especially depending on you know Church
background and history you know not
everyone obviously we have folks who
visit the table who like maybe never
darken the door of a church in their
life you know um but most folks have and
honestly the experience let's just say
wasn't awesome uh to put it mildly and
so I just yeah we don't take it for
granted that you uh kind of give church
another chance so to speak you know um
yeah and so thank you for for trusting
us enough to to be here and uh yeah I
hope you do feel that sense of love and
and welcome so uh we are wrapping up
It's the final message in our series uh
titled Jesus in politics and uh it's
been it's been quite the journey if you
missed the messages you can go back and
find them on the podcast and uh so in
week one we talked about how Jesus was
he kind of kept his distance from
getting kind of pulled into the the
machine of Judean politics and you know
a lot of people wanted him to be like a
very kind of Earthly Messiah deliverer
ruler king in like a very literal sense
you know and and he was like uh uh uh
not playing that game you know and so U
kind of throughout the series we've been
wrestling with kind of the implications
of that um in week two we talked about
the kind of uh
corrosive uh kind of corrupting nature
of power we call kind of power over and
uh and that that's part of what Jesus we
think was it's kind of resisting there
if you think of the Life of Christ um he
didn't like I think of probably the one
exception I could think of and uh is the
clearing of the temple you know is maybe
about the only moment where Jesus is
like hacked off in his kind of like
taking it out on you know and notably
there it's interesting that it's in a
religious context you know I mean it's
like the one place he was sort of you
know driving out the people was like a
church equivalent you know what I mean
the temple like that's where he was kind
of like okay this is too far you know um
and uh and outside of that there was a
very much a a kind of um not hands off
he was very actively involved and
engaged with people you know but not in
that kind of forceful you know uh turn
or burn again the only exception would
probably be the Pharisees the religious
leaders who he's like yeah I'm worried
for y'all but you know the the so-called
you know Sinners and such Jesus did say
you're dragging the whole nation down
and you know like no no it's Grace Grace
Grace you um so then last week we talked
about those those moments though where
we discern you know okay um what what do
I do though when the maybe the the weak
the defenseless um need a voice you know
the the voiceless need a voice and if I
can be that if I can do that do I kind
of weade in sometimes and potentially
wield some power over uh knowing that
has to be done with Incredible kind of
thoughtfulness and um caution even and
so that was kind of last week and then
this week I want to uh kind of Wade a
little bit deeper into the the idea of
that that thoughtfully and
carefully that uh the kind of mode that
we as Christians should be in uh really
kind of throughout our lives but but
especially maybe particularly when we're
talking about potentially wielding some
you know power over and such and so the
title of my message this week is
contemplative mind compassionate action
and our scripture is Luke chapter 10
verses
38-42 uh which reads as Jesus and his
disciples were on their way
he came to a village where a woman named
Martha opened her home to him she had a
sister called Mary who sat at the Lord's
feet listening to what he said but
Martha was distracted by all the
preparations that had to be made she
came to him and asked Lord don't you
care that my sister has left me to do
all the work by myself tell her to help
me Martha Martha the Lord answered you
are worried and upset about many things
but few things are needed indeed only
one Mary has chosen what is better and
it will not be taken away from
her it's interesting story so this this
narrative really uh really from
Millennia has been interpreted not only
at the we might call the literal level
again I do believe this isn't just a
totally figurative story or something
like I think Mary and Martha they are
real people this really happened um but
the church has also interpret it at what
we might call the figurative or the the
kind of symbolic uh level uh meaning
there that like Mary and Martha are kind
of um types so to speak like
symbols so in in this instance you'd
have Mary would be kind of who right
like the Mary would be kind of the the
um the contemplative the the person of
prayer right she's there with Christ um
sort of um worshiping spending time with
you know while Martha is kind of the the
prototypical symbolic like the doer you
know the she's like getting crap done
you know what I mean like this is uh
what she's good at you know and
uh so and there's something in that like
even though Jesus has a critique of her
um you know there's something really I
think even Christlike about Martha
though right I mean it was Jesus himself
who said um I I call you to be the
servant of all
you know and that's what Marth is doing
right like literally serving others
preparing caring showing Hospitality
like this is a very Christian values you
know kind of thing and uh and and so
maybe one way to kind of bring this into
the political kind of Realm we might say
that again seeing this symbolically Mary
would be the the kind of socially
politically kind of withdrawn Mystic you
know opting to transform or influence
the world through prayer and fasting and
the the kind of mysterious workings of
God's spirit you know and uh who would
Martha be then Martha would be kind of
the you know the activist the not
content to sit back um she's she's like
the organizer the door too canvas sir
the community social worker or to even
kind of take it out of the political
realm strictly I know most of us like
aren't like you know full or even
part-time activists or something uh you
could just say Martha is sort of like us
you know like
very much immersed in the world right
with it I mean I don't know about you
but we all got like the The NeverEnding
to-do list you know that just seems like
you knock one thing off and three more
get at it you know it's just sort of
never it just always and there's always
people right people that need caring for
need love need attention I mean that's I
don't know about you like my life feels
totally like a a Martha kind of life in
so many ways and
so I I think what's interesting though
is if you read this more at the symbolic
kind of figurative level then I do think
the reading shifts a bit in other words
at the literal level I do think Jesus
words hold very true right in essence um
this is towards the end of Jesus life
and I I think at the literal level like
Martha is kind of missing the priority
in this moment you know which is why he
says like hey Mary's chosen the better
thing like this isn't really the time
for like you know just running around
like a chicken with your head cut off
and just doing all the things like pay
attention tune in quiet down you know so
that's the literal level if you kind of
zoom out though and see Mary and Martha
as kind of types you know actually I
think what you get is not a a kind of
you know a putting down so much of um
either Martha or Mary right you don't
you don't really say like oh Mary's
being so lazy and weird you know or
Martha she's just missing it um instead
I I think what we begin to see is that
actually um well maybe we can put it
like this at the end of the day we need
them both that a contemplative and
centered mind leads to wise and
compassionate action right and other
words it's not either or it's both and I
think maybe we could say that we need
the Heart of
Mary in the hands of
Martha we need the Heart of Mary in the
hands of
Martha but the thing is not only just as
individuals and not only as an American
culture but really as kind of a
Protestant Church um I think we're much
better at the
Martha mode would you maybe agree with
that you're like we're just kind of more
comfortable there right we're just more
comfortable saying hey let's get to work
you know let's let's do something let's
let's relate let's let's speak let's
encourage let's organize let's engage
let's let's help you know or again to
put this in the political realm let's
let's rally let's protest let's change
Minds let's you know like let's do a
thing I I uh I came
across uh this wonderful kind of list so
I've been following Richard Roar for
many years now um his Center for
contemplation and action which by the
way you can hear in that name the two
symbols can't you right um and this he
has this
wonderful um kind of they call them
eight core principles and the second one
is this sort of idea of the the kind of
um contemplative mind pairing with
compassionate action and he has an
little essay that like outlines each of
the eight uh kind of founding principles
and so this is what he says in relation
to this this second one um he says I'm
just like you my immediate response to
most situations is with reactions of
attachment defensiveness judgment
control and
Analysis I am better at calculating than
contemplating let's admit we all start
there the false self seems to have the
first gaze at almost everything on my
better days when I am open undefended
and immediately present I can sometimes
begin with a contemplative mind and
heart often I can get there later it is
an hour by hour battle at least for me I
can see why all spiritual Traditions
insist on daily prayer in fact morning
midday evening and before we go to bed
to see I think what Roar is getting at
is this is more simply saying you
know if we're going to really do
things sometimes we've got to rest we've
got to take a break and renew
ourselves I think that's
true that's not what Roar is getting at
here so what what's he getting at he's
naming that the Mind our mind all of us
it is Trixie and
false we have this egoic aspect of
ourselves this deep sense of fear this
this uh I mean I don't know about you
I'm feeling the fear right now like you
know what I mean like this this um
deep this sense of
self-preservation you know this need to
control and when it is running the show
it's likely that as Martha esque as we
are do in all the things what what's
very possible is that we are not only
not helping things right socially
politically etc etc uh but we may in
fact be making things
worse like that's the kind of scary
Insight here like just imagine like you
commit yourself you know your life to
like the betterment of
humanity you know you're like doing all
the things and yet you look
back and realize like oh my
gosh I
just messed things up
more like that's such a
sobering
thought that that we could even with the
best of intentions like end up actually
bringing more hell to Earth than
heaven so sobering but when we can quiet
down when we can become as my good
friend Charles Kaiser says a calm
settled presence I know he got it from
someone else but it's a good it's a good
line a calm settled presence now what
happens now hear me now we can begin to
discern what to
do now we can begin until
then we can't discern we can't discern
to take uh a parenting analogy which I
know I do too many of these but it's my
season of life like when when my mind is
on fire with
emotion I am I am the worst parent I am
the I am the I am and no matter how like
I have I will have these moments where
I'm like okay chill chill chill it's
good going in there like I have Clarity
but I start feeling the feelings are
like Rising you know what I mean and
then before I know it the words coming
out of my mouth I'm like I can't control
them you know I just wish I take them
all back uh right this is I me even
Jesus who talked about right the mouth
speaks like from the Overflow of the
heart from the from the the mode we are
in and so we it's only when we begin to
discern um or really kind of settle in
that that kind of calm centered place
now we can discern what Christ would
have us do now we can discern the loving
gesture the compassionate word the
appropriate
action uh Dorothy day was an activist
one of the founding members of the
Catholic Worker social um movement C
Catholic Worker movement it was founded
in
1933 um it was her and a man named Peter
Marin they had this U kind of burning
desire to just express love to the poor
they wanted they wanted Justice and they
wanted um just they called it charity
but they meant sort of oldfashioned word
for just love and they wanted to express
this so they um they got busy they they
started these what's called Hospitality
houses um started them all over the
country I mean they're honestly there
you can go to one at least last time I
heard I visited one in Austin like 10
years ago I don't know maybe it's not
there anymore um but these are still
kind of dotting the country it's
basically places where anyone could go
and find some shelter find some care
find a hot meal um they started soup
kitchens they started these Hospitality
houses um she was writing for the
Catholic Worker that was like a famous
like kind of magazine I think you can
again um still get that um uh get their
newsletter whatever it's probably online
now and um she's writing like article
after article after article for that I
mean she was like in other words she was
totally a Martha like I mean talk about
bsy like she was G situation I believe
she was divorced so she but she had a
daughter so she's like somehow doing all
this raising a kiddo um incredibly you
know Martha esque and um and yet at the
same time
she was a mared at heart she went to
church um not every week she went every
single day Roman Catholic mass every
morning you know that was her thing and
uh she was known to pray for hours hours
and hours each day um I found a few
quotes from her on this she said uh she
said this my strength returns to me with
my cup of coffee and the reading of
is that good another place she said I'm
convinced that prayer and austerity
prayer and self-sacrifice prayer and
fasting prayer vigils and marches are
the indispensable
means in
love all these means are useless un L
animated by
love see I think Dorothy Day understood
she knew to do this work well she would
need not only
the hands of Martha she would need the
Heart of
Mary I think also of Daryl Davis Blues
musician an African-American man who has
for the last 30 years intentionally
befriended members of the Klux Clan
first time I heard this story I was like
this is not a real thing and it
is um Davis he well kind of what he saw
was
um well he started attending their
meetings and then eventually going to
their
rallies and he said um he realized like
these folks they hate me they don't even
know me they've never they've never met
me they never spoken to an
African-American person like they they
don't they don't know anything he
realized like some of the ignorance
there and
so he said I just went in ready to um
listen
to
befriend and then understand where
they're coming from and then as I'm able
I begin to speak once i' gained their
trust I begin to speak to
them he said
um once the Friendship blossoms the
clansmen begin to realize that their
hate may be misguided
Davis's friendship has led over 200
clansmen over these 30 years to give up
their robes he said in fact that he
collects them they bring them to him and
he he collects them and has like a giant
collection of Clans robes and stuff in
some closet or something maybe by now he
might need a storeage June I don't know
you're just like Gathering these things
and he said though he keeps them um
because they become a reminder to
him a reminder of the dent he's making
and hatred in this world a
a reminder that he can make a difference
it turns out in doing a little digging
Davis is in fact a Christian um I
couldn't find anything about his own
kind of piety or you know personal
spiritual practice um maybe I mean
knowing he's a famous Blues musician
probably music plays a big you know part
in his life but um I I'll say this doing
the work he's doing you cannot do that
without entering into that space as a
calm settled presence correct like
that's just that's going to go very
sideways very quickly unless you're just
embodying that and I think in many ways
um that's sort of the the heart of this
whole message is like it's not to say we
we all need to imitate Dorothy Day or
Daryl Davis or like this is a a unique
Grace and a call for them you know I
think what we need to do
is um is kind of discern again what God
would have us do in other words as as I
become a calm settled presence right
suddenly the wise word the loving action
will be born within me right and and
notice there that this is something we
receive it's a gift it's born within us
like where does it come from it's a
mystery I mean it's God we don't even
know how it happens suddenly
we know what to do you ever been in a
moment like that where suddenly you know
what to
say you know what to
do that's that's the spirit speaking
through moving through you but but when
your mind's on fire that you can't you
can't discern in that way but once we
calm down suddenly we can you see
ultimately it is the love beauty of
Christ that will save the world
politics fighting for justice
protesting while sometimes necessary as
we discussed last
week ultimately they are a stop Gap they
are a fire break they are plan B for a
world gone terribly wrong plan a is the
love and beauty of Christ plan a is the
fruit of the spirit manifesting in our
Our Lives as a result of our own
willingness to undergo what we might
call Divine therapy plan a is becoming
that calm settled presence so that we
too can overflow with this
transformative love may we all find the
Heart of Mary hands of Martha in this
season especially in this season in the
name of the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit
amen so on the night Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples and during that meal he held
up a loaf of bread and he broke it he
said this is my body that's broken for
you and when he held up a cup of wine he
said this is my blood shed for you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup remember me so as we to
the table of the Lord tonight as we take
in the body of Christ in the bread the
blood of Christ in the wine may we
receive that Heart of Mary may may we
receive the gifts of the
Spirit so the way we'll partake tonight
is um we will just go kind of row by row
here starting at the front we'll work
our way back we just form one line right
here in the middle um we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning that if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate then you are totally free to
do that regardless of your exact like
denominational affiliation or you know
exact beliefs or whatever if you want to
connect with the Risen Christ then you
are free to do that having said that
there's no pressure either if you're not
in the place where you want to do that
that's fine um you should know the red
is wine the white is grap juice and then
finally you can just partake whenever
and however you'd like some folks like
to kneel here at the front um some
return to their seats but um no one will
lead you through the exact like moment
of so this is the table
not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more
so you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you who have
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here come to
[Music]
for
would you guys stand with us as we close
out with this last song
[Music]
blessed are the ones who do
not all the broken pieces of their
heart blessed are the tears of all the
wey
pouring like a sky falling
[Music]
stars blessed all the wounded ones in
morning brave enough to show the Lord
their
scars blessed are the hurts that are not
[Music]
he open to the healing touch
God the kingom is
yours the kingdom is
[Music]
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on him
the
[Music]
world even in the face of great
abuse blessed are the Deeds that go
un serving with Ard gratitude
[Music]
blessed are the ones to fight
force longing for the com day
of blessed is the soul that thirst for
rightousness will could be the last the
L the kingom is yours
the kingom is
[Music]
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
him the kingom is
[Music]
your the kingom is yours
hold on a little more this is not the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
w
[Music]
w w
oh blessed are the on to suffer
[Music]
vience still have strength to love their
enemies blessed is the faith of the
those who
first
they know
defe the kingom is
[Music]
yours the kingdom is
yours hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is the Lord keep your eyes
on the kingom is
yours the kingdom is
[Music]
yours hold on a
little this is not the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
hold on a little more this is not the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on
[Music]
him thank you so much for joining us
this evening
if you are new and would we would love
for you to fill out a card at the table
on the way out um or just scan the QR
code on the screen to F out the visitor
information
um as a reminder we have meetups uh
those are going on all the time those
can also be found on the website so once
again go to the QR code um love my
meetup group that meets on Saturday
mornings we just started a new book um
but it's a great way to connect with
people outside of just the sometimes in
and out we get caught up here in this
building way um and then don't forget
tonight hat Creek come sit down
fellowship with us have a good time um I
will be there if you I will talk to
anybody ask my wife
um but before we do that let me send you
off with a bit
addiction um if you want to put your
hands out in
a uh in a blessing format or if you just
want to stand and receive that is fine
um you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and it's true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy and you you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts and Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with be blessed we'll see you
next Sunday thank you so much bye on
Friends the kingom is
yours the kingom
is
your hold on a little more this is not
the
end hope is in the Lord keep your eyes
on hold on a little more this is not the
on him
[Music]
nice job you
guys sorry that I mess up the drums on
that last I was struggling
El